Our recent CHRISTMAS LECTURES were all about
human space travel.
So obviously we had to talk about zero-g and
weightlessness, which are some of the most
fundamental experiences of being in space.
This led to some discussion in the office
about what weight is.
I thought it'd be good to unpick in a video
some of the issues that came up,
because actually I think there's a lot of
subtlety, dare I say it some confusion, in
the way people talk about the physics of weight.
One of the biggest misunderstandings is around
the use of the term 'weightlessness', which
lots of people assume means that in space
you don't have any weight.
But this isn't true.
This misunderstanding isn't because the definition
of weight is confusing at all.
It's actually really simple, and exactly as
you learn it at school.
Weight is just the force on an object due
to gravity.
Or if you want to be more precise, it's the
size of the gravitational attraction between
me and the earth,
or the ball and the earth, or this cup, this
chicken, and the earth.
The problem I think is that the way we learn
about weight at school
doesn't quite capture the way that people
think about weight and experience it in real
life.
As I sit here, I can say that I can feel my
weight bearing on my feet and bum, even inside
my body.
But is really my weight that I'm feeling?
Remember what we just said: my weight is just
the force of attraction between me and the
Earth.
But there's clearly a lot of stuff between
me and the centre of the earth:
the floor, the ground, a load of magma...
As the force of gravity pulls me down, repulsive
forces are set up within all that stuff,
and at the interfaces of all those objects,
and these are intermolecular and inter-atomic
forces accumulating all the way to the centre
of the earth.
The end result of that is that I just sit
here, not falling.
Those forces oppose and counteract the effect
of gravity.
So the really important point here is that
you don't really feel your weight either.
It's all of these other forces that support
you that you experience as weight.
This is where the confusion comes in.
When we use the term 'weightlessness' in the
context of space and astronauts,
we aren't talking about an absence of weight
itself, but an absence of what you experience
as weight on earth.
In other words, the absence of the opposing
forces that support you.
Confusion around this had led to another misconception,
that there is no gravity in space.
But gravity is everywhere. The universe is
filled with gravitational fields, you can't
escape them.
So the idea of being weightless due to the
absence of gravity makes no sense at all.
Interestingly, the effect of the Earth's gravity
doesn't change that much when you go into
space anyway,
at least into low earth orbit, like the astronauts
on the International Space Station.
The altitude of the ISS is about 400km, which
sounds a lot,
but is only actually about 6% of the radius
of the earth,
so gravity there is almost as strong as it
is on the surface.
What's really happening in space is that there's
nothing to counteract the effect of gravity.
There are no opposing forces to hold you up,
so instead you just fall freely.
With the ISS, which looks exactly like this,
this is exactly what's going on.
It's not floating or hovering, it's just falling
like anything else towards the centre of the
earth.
It's just going so fast, that it overshoots
and overshoots and overshoots,
until it eventually finds itself back where
it started, and goes round again.
So weightlessness is just a state of unopposed
motion under gravity,
all you need to do to create weightlessness,
is drop something.
When you do that, you remove all of those
opposing forces, and the object falls.
This is how we can create temporary weightless
environments, like in aeroplanes like the
'Vomit Comet',
which deliberately fly along paths to simulate
freefall.
So I think the difficulty reconsiling this
formal definition of weight, with ideas like
weightlessness
comes from this conflation of these two slightly
different ideas:
on the one hand, you have the weight you learn
about in school, as a gravitational attraction,
on the other hand you have the slightly subtler
idea of weight as something you experience
and feel.
In the CHRISTMAS LECTURES we really wanted
to get into this equivalence between freefall
and weightlessness.
I think physicists would normally say weightlessness
is a consequence of freefall,
but maybe with this view of weight, it'd be
better to say that freefall is a consequence
of weightlessness.
As soon as you stop exerting other forces
on an object, it has no choice,
like Wile E Coyote, but to fall under gravity.